- [Voiceover] Hello
grammarians and historians
and linguists and friends.
David here along with Jake.
- [Jake] Hey.
- [David] And Paige.
- [Paige] Hello.
- [David] And I want to
continue our discussion
of the history of the
apostrophe, in English,
and what I'm having Jake
draw for me right now
is an old English King because what's...
The story of the possessive
apostrophe, in English,
is really the story of old English.
Like, how did we get this
like Paige's and Jake's?
How did we get that ending
up as our possessive form,
in English, with that apostrophe s.
Because it didn't always
used to be that way.
It didn't always used to be apostrophe s.
Oh, that's very nice, Jake.
- [Jake] Well, I try.
- [David] So, that's King Ethelred.
So, okay, when we're
talking about, you know,
the possessive in English is very strange
because it's this relic from history
of these forms left over from old English.
So, here's this table, this
vastly simplified table.
English used to have these
things called case endings.
And this is not a very, this is like
a super-simplified version.
These are all, what are called,
the strong case endings.
They were strong and weak
case endings for each gender,
and, in English, we have
masculine, feminine, and neuter.
But the important thing to remember, is
that the singular form of the neuter
and the masculine was es,
and that just sounds like
gobbledyook right now, I get it.
So, let's take our king,
which in old English
would have been cyning, right,
and so if we're gonna look this crown.
Well, in old English, they
would have just used the Latin,
corona, so we're just gonna
refer to this as a hat.
So, if we want to talk
about the king's hat,
in old English, we would use
the special possessive ending,
the masculine possessive ending, right,
because English had a
million of these endings.
There was one where if you
were the subject of a sentence,
you would use that ending.
If you were the object of a sentence,
The Norman Invasion lopped all those off
along with a bunch English heads,
and now we have a much
more simplified language
for better or worse.
If we're talking about the king, here,
we can refer to this guy's hat
as secyninges haet
which might not be the most accurate,
but, you know, Beowulf
isn't around to correct me.
So, if we're looking at
this cyning, here, right,
the possessive ending is this es.
If, for example, we had,
and I'm gonna draw a queen
that's not gonna be as nice,
Queen Pun Hilda.
So the difference between...
So, okay, so the old English word
for queen was, perhaps
unsurprisingly, cwen,
and if we're gonna talk
about the queen's hat,
we would use this singular,
strong, feminine genitive ending
which is cwene, right, with an e.
So, secwene haet,
and that's where all of this started.
Okay, so we have this really
ludicrously complicated system.
Even this table is simplified, right?
Like I've left out half of it,
but, ultimately, what it boils down to
is secyninges haet, secwene haet.
And as we move through history,
what happens is the French invade,
and they say, "Uh, this
system is very complicated.
"Let us get rid of it," and they do,
and it basically leaves us with,
by the time we get to middle English,
the following.
So, by the time we get to middle English,
we have the kinges hatte,
and we have the quenes hatte.
And what's happened is this old English
masculine and neuter genitive,
this possessive form, has just become
the norm for everything.
Everything is now masculine-ized.
For better or worse, that's like,
everything has been
simplified in that direction.
That's part one.
Okay, so hold that in your head.
Okay.
Then, so (laughs) that's middle English,
And then, the printing
press gets invented.
Now, all of the sudden,
people are writing texts
in English all over the place,
but nobody knows how to spell yet, right?
So, we've got that possessive form,
and then we have, what's
called, the his possessive.
So, at this point, we're
in modern English, right,
and so some bit of middle
English and old English
have fallen away.
But so, for example,
we're still looking at something
like, "The kinges hat,"
but what we're starting
to see in this one weird
little period between like the late-16th
and early-17th centuries.
This brief fad for this thing,
where people went, "the king
"his hat."
And, if you can imagine, like,
post-Elizabethan era Londoner saying this,
it kind of sounds the same, to my mind,
"The kinges hat," "the king his hat,"
right, like you're losing...
This 'h' is kind of swallowed.
- [Jake] So, nobody knew how to spell
because there was no way to spell.
- [David] Right, like, Samuel
Johnson had not yet written
the first dictionary,
and that's like 1720.
- [Jake] Uh-huh.
[David] I'm pretty sure.
There were no standards,
not because people were dumb
or anything, certainly not.
It's just that these
standards didn't exist.
Like, in the great scheme of history,
there's stuff that we do now, you know,
that 400 years from now
people are gonna look back
at us and be like, "Phh, you
used words to communicate?"
You know, like we have no idea.
So, what starts to happen
is this thing,
the king his hat, becomes
more and more common
to the point where people
just sort of understand it
as a given, and it starts to
get collapsed to save space.
So, the king his hat
becomes the king's hat, like so.
And just this one weird, fad usage,
which you could even argue
is like a folk entomology,
or something made up.
It doesn't matter.
It happened.
It's attested in print, and
this is how it was collapsed,
and, what happened as
a result of this usage,
is the same thing happened to this.
So, the kinges hat became
the king's hat, and it
was just well, frankly,
because if you were talking
about the queen's hat,
in this his possessive context, it just...
You'd either have to do the Queen her hat,
which is fine, I suppose,
or the Queen his hat,
which doesn't make a ton of sense.
- [Jake] And if you're
wondering how there can be just
this random change in sound in a language
without anybody orchestrating it,
think of a time where say something like,
"I'm gonna go to the store."
"I'm gonna..."
What are you really saying there?
It's a contraction of, I am going to.
Nobody actually says, "I
am going to go right now."
They say, "I'm gonna go."
So, words are always kind of mashing
into each other.
- [David] If you remember
from an earlier video
when Paige and I were
discussing the principle
of least effort, that's
what Jake is getting at.
Is, "the tongue is lazy."
Don't feel bad, but "the tongue is lazy."
Yeah, so what happened was, you know,
this thing became...
And pretty soon,
everything became this way.
So, because of this
one strange little fad,
what we call the Saxon possessive,
this thing, the kinges, the cwenes,
eventually just became king's
and queen's, like so.
- [Jake] How elegant.
- [David] Thank you.
Jake, Paige, does this square with how...
I mean, this is how apostrophes
are used in English,
but Jake and Paige,
you all were telling me
about all the many ways
that apostrophes are used
in other languages around the world.
- [Jake] Right, well I think, you know,
punctuation marks are tools
just like any other tools
that human beings use.
- [David] Uh-huh.
- [Jake] And they can be used
different ways in different languages.
So, in Dutch, apostrophes are used
to make plurals.
- [David] What?!?!
- [Jake] For words that end in a vowel.
- [Jake] So.
- [David] Okay.
- [Jake] Photo in Dutch, is f-o-t-o,
and if you want to have
multiple photos, well,
you have to throw in an apostrophe.
You have to throw in an apostrophe
before the s.
No good reason why that's the case.
That's just how they do it.
Conversely, Dutch does
not put an apostrophe
for possession.
So, if you wanted to say, Jan's book,
you would just say J-a-n-s.
- [David] Oh, so it kind
of retains this genitive.
It retains this possessive form.
- [Jake] Right.
Same thing with German.
- [David] So how do we say, "Jan's book?"
Jans book, like that?
- [Jake] Uh-hum.
- [David] Okay.
- [Jake] Same thing with German.
German is a little bit more conservative,
and that it retains the es.
So, "Das Buch" might mean the book,
in German, and if you want
to say, "Of the book,"
or if you want to say, "The book's,"
you'd say "Des Buches" with that es ending
tagged onto "Buch".
- [David] Oh, the same
one as in old English.
- [Jake] Right, so
since English is kind of
a cousin language to German.
- [David] Uh-huh.
- [Jake] You can see
which way the ball fell
on these two languages.
- [David] Wow! That's super cool.
Paige, any insights from Danish?
- [Paige] Yeah, so from my limited,
you know, expertise in Danish,
people who speak Danish tend
to abbreviate like all their words.
Like, everything gets
shortened all the time.
- [David] Sure.
- [Paige] So, the
apostrophe is sometimes used
in a similar way to how it is here
to sort of show what's being shortened.
- [David] Okay.
- [Paige] So in Danish,
to say something like,
"Take me with you."
- [David] Uh-huh.
- [Paige] You would say,
"tag mig med"
- [David] Tag mig med
- [Paige] So then, you can
shorten that first word,
in writing, by getting rid of the g
and adding an apostrophe.
- [David] Okay.
- [Paige] This actually
doesn't happen much.
It kind of has limited use,
but it's similar to how we use it
for contractions in English.
- [David] Sure.
- [Paige] And like, how
this possessive was formed.
It's interesting that the possessive,
the modern possessive in English,
is just a form of contraction.
- [David] Yeah.
- [Paige] It's bizarre.
- [David] Well, folks, thank you so much
for joining me on this journey
through the wacky history of
the apostrophe, in English.
- [Jake] Thanks for taking us.
- [Paige] Yeah, it was fun.
- [David] Anytime.
And remember, folks, you can learn anything.
David out.
- [Paige] Paige out.
- [Jake] Jake out.